michael rubin and fanatics just pulled
off probably the most savage business
deal of all time this is nuts what they
have done fanatics has built a absolute
monster of a business and they've never
even sold a single product here's
exactly how this occurred fanatics
launched a trading card business six
months ago they then brokered exclusive
deals with the nfl major league baseball
nba and its player associations by
offering them equity in the new business
very savvy business move
tops which had those deals watched its
valuation crumble after it lost its
exclusive major league baseball license
and was forced to cancel its plans to go
public at a 1.3 billion valuation
fanatics essentially killed the top's
business then fanatics used its new
license agreements as leverage to go out
and raise 350 million dollars at a 10.4
billion dollar valuation without ever
producing an actual card fanatics then
used that fresh pile of cash to buy tops
for 500 million dollars representing a
massive discount to their previous 1.3
billion valuation michael rubin the
founder of fanatics is on another level
in terms of execution right now he was
able to build a business from scratch he
was able to go find the exclusive
license deals he was literally able to
kill his only competitor and then he
turned around and he used his balance
sheet to buy them michael rubin and
fanatics killed tops and then scooped up
the scraps as they go forward to try to
dominate whether it's physical cards or
digital cards like nfts michael rubin
fanatics and the top steel may be the
most savage business deal that we've
ever seen joe what's your thoughts in
terms of watching this play out here
this is nuts yeah this was in the huddle
up newsletter this morning for anyone
who wants to go and uh read some more
details you can go to readhuddleup.com
and check it out all right back to the
good stuff so yeah michael rubin savage
savage so fanatics everyone should know
by now they do uh merchandise retailing
for basically all the major sports
leagues the nfl the nba the mlb premier
league formula one and so on they're an
18 billion dollar company massive
massive massive business they were
valued at like four to six billion only
like one or two years ago so the
business blew up during the pandemic uh
the exclusive rights are obviously
extremely valuable so michael rubin said
hey how can i use these relationships
that i've built with the league and
infiltrate other areas of the sports
market we have a database of 80 million
fans that's growing by 10 million more
every single year that we sell products
to so he went to the major sports
leagues here in north america the mlb
the mba and the nfl and said let me take
over your licensed business for trading
cards they were previously with
companies like tops and panini and
others and said uh okay what do we get
out of this michael rubin just as he has
done with his other companies gave them
equity in the new venture so their
incentives were aligned and said let's
go build this together so he gave them
equity in the business and then they
gave him the exclusive licenses these
other companies got screwed because then
the license is what they built their
business on and michael rubin went for
it so the interesting part now is he got
all these licenses but everyone was like
hey man you've never produced a card
you've never marketed this stuff you
never distributed any of this stuff you
have really no experience when it comes
to this and he's hired good people and
he's got the the right people in place
to make this happen everyone thinks but
ultimately like he had never done it so
you go out and you raise 325 or 350
million dollars at a 10.4 billion
valuation and everyone starts asking
questions like hey you've never actually
sold anything why is this company worth
that much the license are obviously
important but ultimately you've got to
sell things so now he circles back and
he goes back and buys tops the same
company that was valued at 1.3 billion
lost the license didn't do their ipo or
didn't go public via spec and now he
buys them for 500 million dollars insane
insane insane business move very
strategic considering he literally
created if you really think about it
this business didn't exist six years ago
they've never sold a product never made
a product to my knowledge right they got
these licenses and they created 10
billion dollars of economic value out of
thin air fnatic still owns about 80
percent of it so they they created about
8 billion worth of
value for themselves and the other
shareholders
own about 20 of it so about two billion
dollars including investors and leagues
and so on so crazy crazy crazy business
move here extremely strategic extremely
smart and it's gonna be interesting to
see like how this goes right because if
you have a ten billion dollar company
now that went and acquired another
company has all these rights and stuff
like how big can this get obviously
investors believe in the future of this
and believe that it can get much bigger
but ultimately like this is just a
savage move
john what did you think when you saw it
michael rubin is one of
the best entrepreneurs i have seen in a
long time
i would put him up there with some of
the great entrepreneurs simply because
he's been an entrepreneur his entire
life starting with you know he did
wholesale for skiing equipment and
snowboarding equipment and he's moved
fanatics into i think a unique position
with these ip of the leagues i think
it's one of the most valuable things you
can get
in that space he's also he sold fanatics
re-bought fanatics back
and then also look he just got
distribution he just got manufacturing
and he just got a whole network of uh
resources along with that purchase of
tops it's a no-brainer for him and i
think the biggest flex possible is that
he's been traveling around the world for
uh for christmas and new year's on a
boat on planes and he's been negotiating
this deal the entire time just speaks to
the guy's work worth
work ethic the the thing that i think
about michael rubin is that i'm not sure
i i'm sure there's people that i'm not
thinking of off the top of my head but
he understands incentives and aligning
incentives in business better than
anyone i've ever seen and what i mean by
that is every company that he's created
fanatics or other things he always looks
to see how he can align incentives in a
strategic way and the way he's typically
done that is he went to these leagues
and said hey look you're getting paid a
licensing fee someone is paying you
whatever it is a few million bucks 10
million bucks 50 million bucks whatever
it ends up being depending on the league
in capital each year in cash and you're
getting that fee but you're not getting
any of the upside right if they go sell
this x amount of money or they go sell x
amount of or why you're not really
getting any of that extra equity upside
so what he did is he created this
company and said i'll do it with you and
i'll give you a percentage of the
business so he gave them equity in
fanatics and then they went out and he
did that with four five six seven eight
different leagues now they're expanding
into college they're doing all these
different things not only is he paying
leagues money but he's also generated
them hundreds of millions of dollars and
billions of dollars on a combined basis
in equity value by building these
businesses up over time he obviously got
super super super super rich off it also
the company's worth 18 billion dollars
he owns a majority percentage of it so
a lot of times it's it's better to have
a smaller piece of the bigger pie right
and he still owns a substantial stake
but ultimately what enabled him to do
this is giving up small pieces of equity
to these leagues aligning incentives so
then they're not even worried about like
think about tops for example they lost
the exclusive license and they lost
their entire business literally the
business cratered in value they couldn't
sell these cards because they don't have
the license anymore so they went from a
1.3 billion valuation to selling the
trading card business at 500 million
massive massive massive discount because
their incentives weren't aligned and
they didn't have the exclusive
partnership so the whole goal is like
for reuben is now hey i'm just going to
continue building these businesses with
these leagues that already have good
relationships with and we're going to
create value for not only myself our
shareholders but also these leagues
which has ultimately ended up being like
a really good strategy for him